[Music]
joining me today is a second amendment
advocate the founder of empowered a
movement of women on college campuses to
feel empowered when they use their guns
for self-defense and a woman who is
black armed and conservative
Antonio before welcome to the Reuben
report thank you thank you for having me
black hair armed and conservative heads
are exploding right now I know that
rippling across the internet oh yeah oh
yeah I'm sure that that's why I love it
that's intentional
you're a rabble-rouser yeah you're going
right at it laughs charming sir if I got
that right off your website that's what
it says yes that really I mean it must
make people crazy just when they just
see that the amount of judgment you must
get must be off the charts right yeah
well in this day and age just to be any
three of them especially together any
combination it makes people upset of
course you know anything makes me feel
closer these days we're going to let it
eventually bat I mean maybe black charm
and liberal blocks armed and leftist but
black armed and conservative forget
about it yes you serve it with that
that's the one that probably people get
most annoyed that it probably is and
I've had people tell me while you kind
of alienate people by saying it's cause
you're conservative like well what I'm
going to say we'll live it to make it
easy for you to you know to digest
I mean I'm conservative you know what
people know about conservatism is that
there is a social conservative and that
is the fiscal conservative and you
contemplated that but yeah I don't think
in this day and age people don't like
that word
and they've seen different things and
you say conservatives all right so we're
going to get to some of your
conservatives yes yeah and we're going
to get to some of the gun stuff
yeah and I guess we get to some of the
black stuff for that too but let's just
tell me a little bit about yourself you
grew up in Dallas Texas girl I am do
still live there now right I tell you a
little bit about about growing up were
you always you're always laughing yeah I
was always why I will say that that
well this ain't it again you can see it
you can change it a a blond-haired
blue-eyed girl can tell her tell someone
that she is black not a Blackfoot
Nigerian now which I'm really upset
because my parents are from Nigeria so
wait is that right not only can you be
this absurd thing which is transracial
which is white people now saying yeah
well you can actually pick a nationality
well Rachel how not their last name oh
yeah those all and she chose a black
last Nigerian last name and it was funny
because that same week that happened was
when blog Twitter attacked me and
apparently some blogs that were nigerian
american blogs that were upset with me
and called me they said that I was a
disgraced Nigerian name the same time
they're praising that which is why
people call this white woman that
decides that she's gonna be it a night
in nineteen American and therefore she's
she has more praise than I do
yeah that's the world we're in right now
are various Apple women why were they
upset at you there because I general
assessment for the wall can I take a
picture with Tommy Lehren how dare I
oh yeah a disgrace to the black name but
especially to Nigerian name I was like
you know I'm a Nigerian so therefore I
know they the only way to be just to
actually disgrace my dream name is if
you're not a doctor a lawyer or engineer
oh I'm really sure you're you're all set
so yeah that's really been tolerant side
by association and then you're friends
with Tommy and you have done stuff on
the blaze and all that and that guilt
though it's interesting to me because
just maybe two or three months ago when
Tommy was on real time I was in the
audience that night and I took a picture
at the after party with Tommy and I had
a nice chat with her and then I took a
picture with Bill and I had a nice chat
with him and it was I didn't see anyone
on the right that was attacking me for
taking a picture with Bill they're like
I don't like Bill and everything but I
got a ton of hate from people on the
left for talking to Tommy and that sort
of disconnect like these the hatred
isn't even on both sides at the moment I
don't know and it's I mean yeah how many
times I mean only using why they knew
about that is because Tommy retweeted my
picture with her and she had me on her
show to talk about empower
and I was really grateful for that but
it's really not the sad part is says
okay what do guys regards you believe
heard or agree with her or not I mean
just because you're literally on a show
with someone what's up usually the
premise is that you bring people of
different viewpoints and perspectives
and you talk about and that's
interesting Peavy but that's not
tolerated anymore to be associating with
someone I mean I just think as a black
person though the reverse racism which
is not even reverse racism what was
called what it is it's racism because
the fact that she's a blond-haired
blue-eyed girl and I'm a black woman
therefore we shouldn't associate
especially because she doesn't have the
same ideology as a black person should
have right she should have yes that I
should have right which in an odd way
that is prejudice in itself adamak
prejudging I'm only going to hear what
you tell me over the next hour that's
only the way I'm going to judge you not
by any other absolutely absolutely I
mean Martin Luther King I really believe
would be rolling on this over in her
grave right now the fact that his speech
talking about the content of your
character not the call your skin have
been flipped around these days to really
be to verify their agenda the people on
the radical wefts agenda and and
perpetuate what narratives they have
which is absolutely the opposite of what
he wanted for this country and the
future of his children like he said yeah
all right so let's back up for a second
so just tell me a little bit about
growing up was with yeah Emily
conservative is that black if it is 20
years ago yeah you know what well I'm
going to I'm going to drop some
knowledge there are a lot of if anything
I would say the majority of why people
are conservatives that this is a radical
notion for me to say that but I really
believe it I believe my parents are very
conservative I mean I grew up with their
values and their values are they out of
my business I wanted to have a small
business because I this is how I'm able
to make a living here in America I
believe an American dream education is
how you're going to prosper
you are responsible for your own path
and life and you make that decision all
those I mean even if you go on the
social side being pro-life etc what have
you all of those notions and values I
received my family but yet they are they
vote for Hillary and Bernie last time
they get out I've discussed this concept
with a couple people yeah yeah what's
the disconnect there then you know what
I see to be honest completely is that my
mom will talk about how could the values
that she has but in the end she'll say
oh but the Republicans are racist
oh but considered as a racist it's it's
a calmness effective tool to to really
divide the same values to say don't go
on that side because those people don't
like you they don't like you they don't
like you they hate you because of your
skin color because your sexual
orientation because of who you are as a
person and not the values that you have
and it's sad because I have to deal with
that every day with my manly that's
interesting so you're dealing with that
but how much actual racism are you
dealing with from on the right because
for example just yesterday you were at
you shot a video with Prager you though
yeah I think in a couple weeks I did
something with Prager you I got a lot of
hate from people on the left saying how
could you work with right-wing Prager
and blah blah blah and all you know all
the usual stuff
you may now get it from the black
community and how could you work with
someone on the right even though they
know you're conservative and but how
much actual racism do you experience
from the right I don't see you know I
will be honest there have been the very
those people who will call Michelle
Obama but you know seriously this has
happened will call Michelle Obama and a
person thing like that that is I mean
regard and I don't know if they're
really conservative or not I mean
they'll act like they are but they might
vote a Democrat last time it really I
see as a people thing and not a biology
especially conservatives and
conservatism is an ideology and you need
to know
your stuff to know if you really are
conservative I mean we see this in this
day of populism and Trump conservative
conservatism does not mean Republican
not mean libertarianism sometimes so of
course you see that I'm not going to say
there's not racism out there on either
side but yeah I've always felt
comfortable and that's the thing is that
most people are not going to get their
little bubble and talk to people that
don't look like them even more so not
think like them that's so rare these
days and that's sad and 2017 that we're
going backwards yeah bad I mean we do
feel like we're going backwards and it's
interesting I've mentioned this before
but when I get invited to colleges I'm
only invited now by the Young
Republicans the libertarians of tomorrow
the freedom people the Liberty this look
at that even though by most accounts gay
married and a choice for you know I'm
against the death penalty I'm for having
some sort of safety net like all of
these things and yet I don't get invited
by anyone on the left so it's like where
is the tolerance again exactly and I'm
so waiting I would love to someone she's
like no what we love your views on
everything else except for the guns but
you know come out but if you an
individual all their own games with them
it would show tolerance if a group on
the left was like you know we're just
going to hear a different view from a
black woman yeah you know you mean just
to play their little identity politics
things exactly the identity politics
which you know I was sick of and you
know I voted for Obama twice 728 in 2008
and 2012 but I 2012 I really started to
get the identity politics part of it
the victimhood mentality part of it and
I really wanted a difference because I
realized it was something different out
there for me that was Rand Paul and I
got really involved quickly with the
Rand Paul campaign and because chemo
justice reform is still something very
important to me and my father went to
prison when I was 5 years old for
mandatory minimums in a drug crime and
I'm different for most conservatives and
that I pushed for criminal justice
reform and
I'm vocal when anybody on the Republican
side tries to you know squelch any type
of reform there and unfortunately we're
gonna seem a little more with you know
Jeff Sessions and and his mandatory
minimum bringing that back again it
would be something to reform the prison
system and make it more functional and
more economically viable exactly those
all should be Republican appellees are
conservative yeah exactly fiscal
conservatives even if you just can look
at that like we've been hearing about
people just on the bunny exactly it was
like okay you could don't talk about the
fact that you don't really care about
people but gonna money let's talk about
the money in the business person you're
saving so much so that's why I mean look
to like Rick Perry in Texas who you know
I mean do I think that he's his big Pro
criminal justice reform advocate now I
mean I just think you the businessman he
brought a lot of business back to Texas
but he also brought a lot of savings
when it came to the prison reform stuff
that he did there yeah does that kind of
show that it doesn't matter sort of
necessarily what intentions are all the
time
I mean like maybe doesn't care at the
personal side which would sort of be
upsetting at some level but if he's
doing the right thing because he's doing
something for fiscal reasons that's
still at the end of the day we're making
it so when when and but there's still
people unfortunately am all three on the
minority but a vocal minority within the
Republican Party not you know I change
something a Democrat Republican and part
of that because I realize I am a
conservative and that's kind of why I
went more on the Rand Paul side because
you know he is very he's I would say and
he had said before he's a fiscal
conservative first and that's what I saw
as a young person in college
realizing that here I vote for this man
Obama and he has Obamacare and that's in
the backs of me and my generation and
then I see that the economy really still
sucks unlike what NPR says I mean Yara
kept telling me this whole time a four
years of in college that the economy was
great it didn't it wasn't negative
oh man oh man hey there
we buy yeah I'm on the Community
Advisory Board semi-carry go just cut
that up but no I'm going to be honest
and you know that's what I heard all the
time is that you know Obama did so much
for not only young people but for black
people and I didn't see I didn't see the
facts for the stats for that that that
wasn't proven and so that's when I
started to realize the fiscal side
especially I was very passionate about
why are we 20 trillion dollars in debt
and that is okay we just have these
blinders on and it's going to be in the
backs of me and my kids and people are
not saying out for students and for my
and for Millennials and that's kind of
why I got more into the campus carry
movement as well because that's another
movement where students were kind of
felt like they were second-class
citizens for a long time yeah so we're
going to dive deep into that yeah I'm a
little bit shy against hacking right now
yeah way I was thinking that's the best
place this knows the best ways not to
get in trouble yeah what would you
define yourself or use the label
conservative as opposed to libertarian
because a lot of the stuff and we talk
about Rand Paul yeah real libertarians
up do you see a difference or is it just
putting airs or you know I think in the
tests and everything that I'm still
libertarian and that's ideology wise I
am I just feel like I'm in this weird
especially in this age of Trump or
populism or whatever where people are
trying to figure out well and I saw
especially during the election with
Austin Peterson and stuff like that
where these conservatives who were
Republican Party but they were more
Conservatory in' and they wanted a place
they wanted a home base but they didn't
really find it in either and so i say
conservative because literally I mean
materialism as long as you don't believe
that it's force that makes that value
you can be a liberal or you can be
conservative but the difference is
there's one half force or not right and
so I think that's why I consider myself
a small L libertarian but really I'm
conservative when it comes to fiscal
conservatism and quiet based social
conservatives
I feel as well so like what kind of
social probably the most is my pro-life
stance that you know I've been always
been pro-life even while as a Democrat
and I think that's all saying is that a
lot of people in minority communities
Hispanic black they're very conservative
and those values and those traditional
values but they still just something
about the Republican Party doesn't fit
well yeah they don't know about the
Libertarian Party yet so when you hear
so for example as someone that's
pro-life when you hear the media will
say well you know if if we take away
funding from Planned Parenthood or we
have any other rules or regulations
around abortion or whatever it is that
that's going to hurt minority
communities most you don't even think
that that that that notion is coming
from the communities themselves oh no
they just let me tell you a story
oh I know 2012 I go to this woman for
Obama luncheon and you know I'm there
I'm excited yeah 2012 another another
four years for Obama and the the head
girls while there was a small business
coalition behind me it was mostly
African American women and they
literally asked the the head person
there that day so I'm not sharing much
about the African American community you
can are you guys gonna be doing any
other any plans for you guys to be
reaching out to them and the woman
literally tell them that well we already
got we've got 95% of the vote last time
we don't really need to focus on them
well there's sort of a refreshing candor
the area uh yeah but I'm pretty sure
didn't know why she was and all sort of
us look at each other I remember and
we're just like what your point yeah
like did she don't say that if she knows
what she just said and it was then I
started to think you know what they
think they have in the bag I mean yeah
that was really your light bulb that was
like wow I've been played this whole
time we can play this whole time you're
right it's 95 percent of us are voting
this the same way where does any other
group that doesn't and I mean even the
Hispanic community tends to you know
they're varied every election that you
don't know exactly but yeah there can I
think they have it in the bag every time
and they take those people for granted
and that's when I started to realize is
he really doing something about
community has poverty levels gone down
since then has welfare gone down since
then are we more dependent on the
government since he's been president
yeah we have that so shown that and I
continue to do my research and that's
the thing is a lot of people will not do
the reasoner and don't know your history
they don't know you know which I'll talk
about later but you know with black
people and guns that they've used that
to protect themselves against um gun
control groups like the KKK or their
history has been that a lot of them have
been conservative or planned parenthood
that that started as a way to and
basically have a genocide of all
minorities in the first place a logical
I'm not going to do the research on that
and so that's why I feel this I don't
say in but as a mission to to use that
to use my my knowledge of that history
and bring it out there and say this is
actually your history and contradictory
to what they're telling you right now
yeah and it's so interesting to get
people that think about this stuff
because you know when when one of the
police shootings happen in Florida and
everybody was talking about well now
ways to get rid of stand your ground and
even though I think we differ a little
bit on guns and we can get to that and
that's great that I remember thinking
wait a minute
you're taking away stand your ground
which means that a black person who's
being attacked might be able to have a
gun and protect himself and yet they
always come in with with more ideas to
actually take the power away from the
people and what the only is good
yeah and I'll always use that one case
and sport of that woman she was
basically she kinda was a victim of
domestic abuse with her husband her her
husband was abusive and where she shot
in the air as a warning shoulder and she
got a mandatory minimums or what 10
years or so actually I think more than
that and I think they change that they
dropped it later on but they always go
back to that case we'll see see black
people I mean that's why guns are not
for black people because you know all
this racism is going to do the opposite
instead of standing your ground if
you're not gonna be able to actually
protect yourself without getting by
what I'm going to jail or or having a
gun without going to jail or being
prosecuted some way so they'll use that
but they won't use the many times that
other people have used it for
self-defense and have not had that case
happen to them I mean it's not about
race it's really it's really about poor
laug about mandatory minimums let's talk
about that let's talk about the criminal
justice reform system let's stop making
about race every single time and then
losing the actual policies and issues
that are important which can actually
change everyone's out yeah when it comes
to that
[Music]
you